اجواء احتفاليه سادت غرفه اخبار قناه
العربيه روح معنويه عاليه بعيدها العشرين
عقدان من المهنيه والمثابره وسنوات من
الفخر بالمشاهد والمتابعه الثاقبه حول
العالم
اليوم يوم تاريخي مميز العربيه يوم نتذكر
في كل انجازات العربيه خلال الفتره
الطويله هذه وهي انجازات من اول يوم
انطلقت في العربيه انطلقت في قناه قدمت
المهنيه قدمت الموضوعيه قدمت الخطاب
الاعلامي المعتدل
مرحبا بكم في غرفه اخبارنا
الاحتفالات بدات مبكرا مع الساعات الاولى
من اليوم ببرنامج صباح العربيه جمع
ايقونات الماضي والحاضر جنبا الى جنب
لاستحضار لحظاتهم التي لا تنسى
استعدنا شريط ذكرياتنا مع اطلاق النشره
الاولى لقناه العربيه في الثالث من مارس
عام 2003 كنا على الهواء مباشره مع طالب
كنعان واليوم عشنا معه هذه اللحظه مجددا
ما زلنا في حاله نوستالجيا التي رسمت على
وجوه زملائنا داخل قناه العربيه بنبره
صوتهم القوي ومع كل ضربه على اوتار
الجيتار
مهد الطريق لانطلاقه يوم مثير
[موسيقى]
لعشرين سنه نجوم المجتمع من مختلف انحاء
العالم شاركوا العربيه بعيدها العشرين انا
اتابع قناه العربيه منذ 20 سنه كل سنه
وقناه العربيه القناه الرائده اللي
بتنقللنا اهم الاخبار القناه اللي فيها
جزء من يومياتنا ويا رب عقبال 100 سنه من
النجاح والتنوير اهني قناتنا الرائعه
والاكثر من رائعه العربيه مناسبه مرور 20
عام على تاسيس التي تمر من هنا
لهما موضع مميز على مدار اليوم زملائنا
الذين وضعوا حياتهم على المحك في سبيل
صناعه القصه الصحفيه لم ننسى تضحياتهم
خسرت قناه العربيه مرسلتها في العراق زميل
اطوار بهجت اضافه الى زميلي
ليعاود مطارده شغفه الاخباري زميلنا
الصحفي جواد كاظم بعد ان نجى سابقا من
هجوم ارهابي عاد الى شاشتنا وظهر بشكل خاص
مع نجله كريم
قبل ايام كنت اسولف لانه انا اقرا نشراتي
فعرف انه عندي نشره على الهواء وهذه قلت
له تعال حتى تصدق انه احنا نقرا على خلف
الكاميرا كان موجود يعني
التقارير واللقاءات والاخبار العاجله لا
تتوقف لكن في الاثناء ننتظر دوما عوده
زملائنا بسلام من تغطياتهم في المناطق
الساخنه
بدايه الحرب كان في عنا طاقم من كريستيان
بيشري مذيعه والمصور طلال المصري كانوا في
اوكرانيا قبل بدايه الحرب لاعداد بعض
التقارير
والمواقف وبديت الحرب وهم موجودين
بالبيدان وقاموا بتقطيع رائع وممتازه ولكن
انا كنت قلق جدا لانه لم يكونوا محضرين
مئه بالمئه لتغطيه الحرب او بدايه الحرب
استمريت بالتواصل معهم بشكل يومي بشكل
دائم حتى يطمئنينا على وضعهم وتم اخراجهم
لاحقا بعد ما ادوا تغطيه رائعه صحيح
فهذه كانت احدى المواقف الكبيره العاطفيا
اللي اثرت
التقنيات العالميه على مدار الاعوام
العشرين الماضيه كانت دوما ما يميز
العربيه لتظهر لكم بصوره عصريه وبحله تلبي
تطلعات مشاهديها تكنولوجيا اللي نحن
اخترناها هي ساعدتنا كتير انه نمر بهذه
المرحله الصعبه ونطلع في الشكل الجديد
للعربيه اللي هو عباره عن عشرين سنه وفعلا
الشكل اللي موجود حاليا
بيعطي
قيمه للعشرين سنه اللي مرت من من القناه
هابي بيرث دي عربيه مع قرب انتهاء اليوم
اجتمعت عائله عربيه لتعزيز هذه الخطوه
البعيده التي قطعناها في سماء الاعلام
لنستعد لانطلاقه جديده نحو مستقبل واعد
وفي الذاكره ماض نعتز به
بجهودكم
اني اكون زميل معكم اليوم مجدا فخور في
العمل معكم واشوف كل العمل والتضحيات
والعمل المستمر وان شاء الله عشرين سنه
قادمه شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]